we are told a phone sells for six
hundred dollars and loses 25
of its value per year
write a function that gives the phone's
value v of t so value is a function of
time t years after it is sold
so pause this video and have a go of
that before we work through it together
all right so let's just think about it a
little bit
and i could even just set up a table to
think about what is going on so this is
t and this is the value
of our phone as a function of t
so it sells for six hundred dollars so
time t equals zero what is v of zero
well it's going to be equal to six
hundred dollars that's what it sells for
time t equals zero now t equals one
what's going to happen
well it says that the phone loses 25
percent of its value per year another
way to rewrite it that it loses 25
percent of its value per year is that it
retains
it retains
100 minus 25 percent of its value per
year or it retains 75
of its
value
per year per year
so how much is it going to be worth
after one year well it's going to be
worth
600
600
times 75
now what about year two well it's going
to be worth what it was in year one
times 75 percent again so it's going to
be 600
times 75 times 75 percent and so you
could write that as times
75
squared and i think you see a pattern in
general if we have gone let's just call
it t years
well then the value of our phone if
we're saying it in dollars is just going
to be 600
times and i could write it as a decimal
0.75
instead of 75 percent to the t power
so v of t
is going to be equal to 600
times
0.75
to the t power and we're done let's do
another example
so here we are told that a biologist has
a sample of 6 000 cells the biologist
introduces a virus that kills one third
of the cells every week
write a function that gives the number
of cells remaining which would be c of t
the cells as a function of time in the
sample t weeks after the virus is
introduced so again pause this video and
see if you can figure that out
all right so i'll set up another table
again so
this is
time it's in weeks and this is the
number of cells c we could say it's a
function of time
so time t equals zero when zero weeks
have gone by we have six thousand cells
that's pretty clear now after one week
how many cells do we have what's c of
one
well it says that the virus kills
one-third of the cells every week which
is another way of saying that two-thirds
of the cells are able to live for the
next week and so after one week we're
going to have 6 000
times
two-thirds
and then after
two weeks or another week goes by we're
gonna have two-thirds of the number that
we had after one week so we're gonna
have six thousand
times two-thirds times two-thirds or we
could just write that as two-thirds
squared so once again you are likely
seeing the pattern here we are going to
at time t equals zero we have six
thousand and then we're going to
multiply by two thirds however many
times however many weeks have gone by
so the cells as a function of the weeks
of t which is in weeks is going to be
our original amount
and then however many weeks have gone by
we're going to multiply by two-thirds
that many times so times two-thirds to
the t power and we're done